please save your seats our program is
about to begin
ladies it down dr. Gary small
thank you Michael how are you now oh
I've got my outside voice fantastic
welcome it's such a beautiful day
we've got snow-capped mountains we've
got the desert the clean air and we've
got a bunch of people who are just
settling down who are interested in what
we're going to talk about today and I
want to thank you for spending time and
coming to hear what I have to say how
many of you would like to live to be a
hundred or beyond
okay settle down how about living well
and healthy to a hundred and beyond
there you go
[Applause]
I'm gonna tell you how to do it but
first meet Madame Jean come on she lived
in the South of France she was
physically active mentally active born
1875 died 1997
okay can anybody do the math 122 you
passed your first cognitive test give
yourself the big and what was
extraordinary about this woman was that
when she died she did not have dementia
she did not have Alzheimer's she was
mentally clear she had that they did an
autopsy on her brain it was the brain of
a healthy 80 year old so there's this
connection between how we behaved during
the South of France are gonna eat that
Mediterranean diet it's good for your
heart it's good for your brain staying
physically active how we behave and how
our brains age now man oh c'mon was also
an astute businesswoman at the age of 94
she sold her apartment to a French
businessman who agreed to let her live
there and pay her rent for the rest of
her life
he died ten years later now this is
extraordinary because we don't all live
that long and in fact in the 19th
century
life expectancy was much shorter but we
have other examples of extreme longevity
pockets of the world these so-called
blue zones where people live to a
hundred or beyond their clusters of
these centenarians places like Sardinia
Italy
Okinawa Japan or not far from here
Loma Linda California and in all these
areas there's a tendency to share these
kinds of healthy brain habits there's
strong social ties people eat a healthy
diet and they're physically active and
this brings us to the formula for
successful brain aging physical exercise
mental stimulation social interactions
other activities that manage stress and
of course let's see what was the other
one
I'll get to that later but trust me
there is a formula there's a book I've
written about this I'd encourage you to
get so you don't forget now this brings
us this whole question of brain health
and when people think about brain health
they tend to think about memory now
memory is important without our memory
we have no past we can't plan for the
future and we can't appreciate the
present so clearly memory defines who we
are but brain health is more than just
memory a very important aspect of brain
health is being able to think and reason
and understand or to have a steady mood
and if you can achieve your brain health
then you're going to be able to remember
and think about all those decisions you
need to make every day to keep your
brain healthy
so it's critically important and what
aspect of brain health you may not be
aware of is inflammation
now inflammation we know is a normal
physiological process that helps us
fight off infection repair damage if you
sprain an angle it gets warm and hot and
swollen that means your inflammatory
cells are doing their job but a problem
as we age is that we get too much
inflammation and that affects our brain
we have heightened inflammation in the
brain and those inflammatory cells
actually attack normal cells we can do
something about it in fact there are
many strategies that I'll be talking
about today that are anti-inflammatory
and help us fight inflammation getting a
good night's sleep how do you feel after
a good night's sleep you feel fantastic
I mean your mind is clear you have more
energy you have fewer aches and pains
because of that anti-inflammatory aspect
of sleep your diet can affect your
inflammation eating fish is an
anti-inflammatory strategy or one of the
best ones one of my favorite is physical
exercise critically important so you
know the other side of brain health the
flip side of it of course is Alzheimer's
disease we're all very frightened of and
we read about it a lot in the news
there's celebrities who have been
affected there's new headlines every day
it's very hard to keep up with it one
day we're saying take vitamin E the next
day we're saying don't take vitamin E so
it's confusing not just for the
scientists from all this information and
if we can keep our brains healthy we can
and fight off Alzheimer's disease now
one of the high
raishin is good for your brain too by
the way one of the biggest questions I
get when I give a talk is what's the
difference between dementia and
Alzheimer's and I'm gonna try to explain
that let's start with Alzheimer's it was
first described in 1906 by ala Wiis
Alzheimer and his patient was a
middle-aged woman who became very
confused quite quickly and she died at
age 55 and what he did he did an autopsy
of her brain and for the first time
showed these abnormal protein deposits
called amyloid plaques and tangles and
you can see them up here on the slide
these tiny little proteins that actually
attack areas of the brain that define
brain health areas were thinking and
memory is controlled now in 1906 the
medical community didn't think much of
it because the woman was in middle-age
it was very rare to see this but in the
late 1960s scientists studied so-called
senility they looked at people who were
old and we used to think that you just
lost your memory as you got older well
they looked inside the brains of these
senile people and they saw the same
amyloid plaques and tangles so now we
have late onset Alzheimer's and it was
quite frightening to the public because
now there's an epidemic of Alzheimer's
disease because we're all living longer
now that was frightening but I'm going
to show you why we can do things about
it now here we see two brains one is an
Alzheimer brain the other is a normal
brain and you can see the Alzheimer
brain is smaller it's atrophy or
shrunken and you can see these in sets
show you where there are high
concentrations of the tangles and the
plaques in the atrophied Alzheimer brain
but if you look at this normal brain if
you look closely you can see an
occasional plaque and an occasional
tangle and what we're learning is that
Alzheimer's disease begins to build up
in all of
brains many years before we even
realized now we've learned that through
modern technology at UCLA we've been
using brain imaging tools like positron
emission tomography or PET scanning to
understand and see how Alzheimer's
builds up in the brain and our team a
number of years ago invented the first
brain PET scan to be able to provide a
measure of the physical evidence of
Alzheimer's disease in living people and
here we see an animation of 20 scans put
together and you see how the brain gets
more yellow and eventually more red that
shows you where Alzheimer's is building
up in the brain and as there's more
Alzheimer's the memory score gets worse
and as the movie loops around these are
people who have traces of the plaques
and tangles but won't get symptoms for
10 or 20 years now when I tell this to
people usually they freak out they think
oh my god I've got Alzheimer's building
up in the brain
I see the positive side of that and that
is that with these kinds of tools we can
identify problems very early so we can
do something about it before there are
extensive symptoms now you know I talked
about for just a moment the formula for
keeping your brain young some of the
things we can do I'm gonna emphasize
that today but genetics comes into play
to some extent there are very rare genes
called mutations that actually cause the
disease but it's extremely rare and it
occurs in families where half of
relatives get the disease often in
middle-age now then that is important
for our research to try to understand
how to help people but for most of us
those kinds of genetic causes are not an
issue there are genetic risks and the mo
the one that's been studied the most is
called a pony for and one out of five of
us has this Jeanette
risk April before it means that were
more likely to get Alzheimer's at an
earlier age but it's not an absolute so
we don't recommend genetic testing for
the average person because lots of
people with April before never get
Alzheimer's and lots of people without
it do get Alzheimer's so it's just a
risk factor not an absolute and it turns
out that studies looking at genetics
versus non-genetic factors show that for
the average person genetics is not as
important as lifestyle choices or
non-genetic factors now if you look at
cognitive health vs. age you see it's a
downhill slope and but we have some
control over it and doctors and
scientists have come up with different
stages of decline and the first one we
call normal aging and this is where
we're forgetting where we put our keys
or I'll walk into the kitchen I'll think
you know why did I walk into the kitchen
I'm sure we've all experienced these
things now generally joke about it and
it doesn't progress too rapidly it tends
to be relatively stable but these kinds
of categories categorizations tend to be
confusing and I've come up with my own
scientific graph based on my own
experience that helps us understand the
aging brain so we have about a third of
the time we're sleeping about a third of
the time we're working and a third of
the time let's see what are we doing oh
yes we're looking for things we just had
a moment ago so I find this a little
more helpful but if we go back to the
the more conventional approach if normal
aging worsens we experience mild
cognitive impairment so here is where
the memory issues are a little more
severe but we're able to compensate and
we kind of fill in and we're still able
to function independently
now when that compensation breaks down
that's what we call dementia that's
where
one's memory is so bad that they need
help from others they're no longer
independent now there's a lot of causes
for dementia Alzheimer's disease what I
described a moment ago is the most
common cause about two-thirds of
dementia are caused by Alzheimer's
disease but you could have a depression
and it could look like dementia and that
can be treated or you could have a
medication side effect or a thyroid
imbalance so it's very important anybody
who's concerned about their memory they
should check in with their doctor to
find out what's going on now we know the
common memory complaints write names and
faces where you put things for getting
an appointment or plan can be very
annoying the tip of the tongue
phenomenon you know that word but you
just blurt it out later and your friend
looks at you like you're crazy it turns
out that we've developed methods to
compensate for all these problems
eighty-five percent of people who
complain about age-related memory issues
complain about names and faces so these
are very annoying but I'm going to share
with you today some of the strategies
we've developed that are very easy that
will very quickly help you compensate
for these normal issues now I wanted to
just uh give you another example of
successful brain aging this is a
photograph my wife took of myself and
her 104 year old grandmother grandma
Holly now in the interest of
transparency I just want to disclose
that I was not injecting myself with
anabolic steroids
and now by the way this is before I
started painting my hair white
but grandma ollie was very short but she
was very feisty she was a very spirited
woman she was on the phone with
relatives and friends all the time which
spoke to her mental engagement and
social engagement she lived in an
apartment in New York where there was no
elevator so she had lots of physical
exercise so she was practicing the brain
healthy lifestyle and she was mentally
very clear throughout her life but every
time we'd visit I would be concerned
knowing her age is a risk factor for
Alzheimer's I'd want to do a Mental
Status exam but she was too proud to let
me do that so I remember this visit I I
said well grandma how old you now and
she said shut up so so she passed her
Mental Status exam very well now
unfortunately not all of us do that well
we don't lived 104 or 122 mentally clear
and we have this downhill slope but what
our goal is is to identify problems
early and intervene early so we can slow
that down unfortunately doctors tend to
do too little too late that we wait
until somebody already has dementia we
can help them there are medicines and
other strategies that help but it's
easier to protect a healthy brain than
to try to repair damage once that damage
is extensive so if you if you take
someone who has Alzheimer's disease and
you give them a placebo or sugar pill
it's not going to help they're going to
go down at a certain rate now we have
medicines are called symptomatic drugs
and you see them advertised on
television now they've been around for
quite some time and they do help to some
extent they don't cure the disease they
provide temporary relief often they can
keep patients in the community longer
because you can stabilize the symptoms
and that's helpful but what we're
searching for right now in the research
is what's called a disease modifying
treatment so you can slow down
that slope of decline now the way of
looking at it is if you had pneumonia
symptomatic treatment would be an
aspirin you'd feel better but it
wouldn't get rid of the pneumonia you'd
need to take an antibiotic which would
be a disease modifying treatment now
unfortunately all the research has been
done so far for that kind of a treatment
that research has failed and there have
been a lot of studies looking at
infusions new pills we're you know we're
starting we haven't failed as yet I'm
optimistic at UCLA we're starting a new
study with focused ultrasound where we
take that diagnostic tool and take those
waves and focus them on memory centers
of the brain to see if we can stimulate
some of the neural connections better
and this research is very important and
we have to continue it and we're in the
midst of it and I'll describe some of
what we've done but while we're waiting
for science to catch up there's a lot we
can do to keep our brains healthy and
that's what I want to focus on in just a
moment here's just an example of the
kind of research we've been doing and
I've been emphasizing how important is
it is to control inflammation in the
brain
a few years ago thanks to the help of
the National Institutes of Health we did
a study where we looked at an
anti-inflammatory drug in people
middle-aged and older who were having
normal memory complaints and we found
that after 18 months those who took the
anti-inflammatory drug actually had
better memory and when we did brain PET
scans we saw there was better brain
function in the front part of the brain
the thinking brain that is able to
understand and solve problems so this
was a positive study it was controlled
with placebo so we had a group that was
taking a sugar pill the problem is that
it was a small study and these drugs
have side effects and other studies have
found that if you give these drugs to
people who already have dementia they
actually have the opposite effect they
can accelerate cognitive decline so
there's probably a tipping
when certain interventions help or
hinder brain health so we've been trying
to explore other safer ways to dampen
inflammation now by the way this is this
is what I'd like to be doing when I'm a
hundred but I probably won't be doing it
because I've never pull volted in my
life but as I've said you don't need the
pole-vaulting gene there are non genetic
strategies that make a big difference
and probably number one if you do
nothing else after today make sure you
exercise every day you don't have to
become a triathlete one study found that
20 minutes of brisk walking can lower
your risk for Alzheimer's disease
anything you can do if you can't walk
your your lower extremities are
bothering you
you know go swimming do anything to get
your heart to pump oxygen and nutrients
to your brain cells the exercise will
increase the circulation of endorphins
which causes the runner's high improves
your mood it also gets your body to
secrete chemicals that get your brain
cells to sprout branches and communicate
more effectively so exercise is
tremendously important we've done
studies others have done studies in fact
a lot of them were done at the
University of Illinois and this is an
example of one such study where they had
older people to start walking every day
a bit and they had a control group that
just did stretching and toning and you
can see in this graph you have the size
of the hippocampus that's a part a very
important memory center of the brain
underneath the temples and you can see
after six months and after a year that
hippocampus keeps growing in size
critically important it turns out that a
bigger brain is a better brain so if
somebody calls you a Fathead it's
actually a compliment
so what about that physical exercise
what about brain fitness and brain
exercise we're hearing about it a lot
how we can build mental muscle very
important there's been a lot of studies
if you speak several languages you have
a lower risk for Alzheimer's or people
who attend college who graduate from
college have a lower risk now we know
that's definitely true about UCLA we're
still tallying the results about USC now
also by the way I did go to USC Medical
School so it's a great institution and
in fact even if you never went to
college what you're doing here at the
book festival lifelong learning
educating yourself protects your brain
from Alzheimer's disease so anything you
like to do games conversations that's
probably going to be good for your brain
health but you know we're in an age
right now where everything is high-tech
and we've got all these devices people
come to my office and they say dr. small
I'm I can't remember phone numbers
anymore I'm very frightened and I'll
tell them look don't don't worry about
your memory because your memory will be
worse and pick and choose what you
commit to memory so we get into this
whole area of the pros and cons of the
technology and there are pros and there
are cons you know it's a challenge for
older people we know that they tend to
use computers and devices less than
younger people although they're now
starting to engage in if they're late
adopters but they still like old-school
kinds of devices like this
you know I had something like this and I
loved it so much I was it was falling
apart and I patched it together with
scotch tape for as long as I could have
it there's debate in the media is Google
making us stupid if there are any
digital natives in the room I want to
point out that stupid is misspelled and
so we were curious about this to
understand it better in at UCLA we did a
study we called your brain on Google we
wanted to understand what the brain
looks like when we're searching online
and I was particularly interested to see
what the brain looked like the first
time someone searches online and I had
to get some volunteers for this I
quickly learned I couldn't recruit them
online I found people like this
congratulations you're the last person
to get an email account we succeeded we
actually recruited a lot of them at
libraries not dissimilar this library
and what we did we put them into the
functional MRI scanner we had them wear
special goggles and we could show them
images that look like online sites and
they had a little mouse at their side so
they could search online in the scanner
so we could measure their brain activity
for a moment-to-moment
and here's what we found I'll just cut
to the chase the colored areas show you
where the brain was engaged and in this
first group these were people who were
internet naive who were searching online
for the first time you see there's some
red in important areas but there's not a
whole lot when we had the people with
internet experience searched online
their brains were having a party there
was more than twofold increase
activation in the brain so just
searching online can be a form of brain
exercise we think that it works like
this is this u-shaped curve that's
turned upside down which works in any
scientific experiment by the way so we
think if you plot brain activation
versus time any time we are confronted
with an unfamiliar task we're a little
confused we're not quite sure what to do
but once we understand it we figure out
a strategy that's when we engage our
brain cells
once we get good at it we get more
efficient and you see less brain
activity now in the debate about
technology there have been a lot of
scientists who have looked at the
potential upside of the technology and
there's a group in the in the Bay Area
that's been studying different brain
games or really video games and here's
one that involves keeping a race car on
a windy road while informative or
distracting signs pop up so it really
teaches multitasking and it turns out if
they have a 70 or 80 year old play this
game for a week or two that individual
can multitask as well as a 20 year old
who's never played the game so it's
really quite remarkable how much we can
do and there are other studies showing
that various brain games do improve
brain activity and in my latest book I
have a whole section on that with
resources if you're interested very
interestingly they found that surgeons
who play video games make fewer errors
in the operating room so the next time
you have to have surgery forget about
asking where they went to college or
medical school how many hours of World
of Warcraft do you play a week or so
we've studied these approaches
systematically of lifestyle approaches
and we find they make a difference we've
had two weeks studies six week studies
we find that subjective and objective
memory improves and we do brain scans we
see there's an improvement in the
frontal lobe of the brain here's a study
using MRI again and the the upper images
show you what we call the brain stress
test so during the scan we gave this
woman a memory task and you see there's
a lot of activity a lot of red so her
brain was working really hard to
remember we put her on the two-week
program that we described in the book
and we repeated the experiment very
little activity what that tells us is
that she's not working as hard and when
we did the memory test
memory scores improved by 200% so it's
it's a bit like going to the gym where
you start lifting weight you're sore you
can hardly do much but if you train you
can lift more weight and exert less
energy and we can do the same thing to
improve our brain now we've had we've
developed some very simple memory
techniques look snap Connect is one of
them look as a reminder to focus your
attention the biggest reason people
can't remember is they're simply
distracted snap is a reminder to take a
mental snapshot of what you want to
remember later this builds on our brains
and Nate visual abilities that have
evolved over many many years and finally
connect is a way of linking up those
mental snapshots so they have meaning if
you can make something meaningful it
will be memorable so let's see how it
works how many of us have forgotten
where we parked our car ok quite a few
it's disconcerting to say the least
so you can use look snap connect for
everyday memory challenges like parking
your car so UCLA we have a lot 3b when I
park in Lot 3b I see three large bees
hovering over my car now if I lock Park
just below it in lot to be I see William
Shakespeare on my car reciting to be or
not to be so does that mean my car is
not to be a lot to be and it's maybe
it's not the best example but these
kinds of techniques you can really
transfer to everyday life so do you
remember her name okay so some people
said grandma some people said Ollie and
so you said grandma because that was
part of the story it had meaning but you
can give her face meaning to the name by
looking at her for a moment of thinking
well she has olive color skin ollie or
here you meet Harry turns out he's got a
lot of hair
I want you to meet Lisa she's got a very
pretty subtle Mona Lisa smile and you
meet mrs. bangle well that's easy she's
got bangs and then she tells you she's
an attorney so that helps you remember
her first name
[Laughter]
now we can use these methods and also
that's an emotional memory by the way if
you've ever been sued you remember it
better just like the three B's over my
car I was stung by a bee so I remember
that better now we can use these methods
to remember Erin so let's say I'm
running out of the house I've got to
remember to get eggs and pick up my
dry-cleaning I see myself holding an egg
it slips and the yolk gets all over my
pants and I remembered to go to the
cleaners so you can remember unrelated
words using this method so I want you to
prove it to yourself here are eight
unrelated words create a mental image
for each word and then link them
together by developing a story and it
could the words can be in any order so
once you just take a moment to look at
the words I'll read them to you beach
professor horse teddy bear cigar nun
palm tree pasta and maybe I'll ask for a
volunteer in a moment so while you're
stressing out about your story let's
talk about stress because it's it's not
good for your brain it turns out that
animals under chronic stress actually
have smaller memory centers in their
brain they get lost in their mazes if
you inject a human volunteer with the
stress hormone cortisol they have
temporary memory impairment now the good
news is we can manage stress better
meditation Tai Chi taking vacations
spending time with friends and family
this can lower stress levels and it not
only improves mood and improves memory
but it actually alters your neural
function a Hell in the varetsky at UCLA
in our division has done studies where
she looks at brain function after people
have done meditation or Tai Chi and you
can see those colored areas on that MRI
scan show you where there is alteration
and neural activity in fact she and
others have studied telomeres so these
are the tips of our chromosomes and it
turns out the the markers of how long
those tell
determine your life expectancy so this
kind of activity can not only improve
your brain health but help you live
better and longer food is very important
when it comes to how well our brains age
and number one is portion control we
have an epidemic of obesity and
overweight which increases the risk for
Alzheimer's disease I mention fish as
anti-inflammatory if you don't like fish
you can try nuts walnuts are very potent
in an omega-3 anti-inflammatories and if
you're allergic to nuts sprinkle some
flaxseed on your cereal you'll get an
omega-3 boost fruits and vegetables most
of us don't get enough fruits and
vegetables they are antioxidants our
brains age there's oxidative stress that
causes wear and tear on those brain
cells another tip when blueberries are
on sale their great antioxidant fruit
frees them because they maintain their
potency in the freezer make great
antioxidant snacks and finally we want
to try to minimize the refined sugars
and the reprocessed foods the chips the
desserts and so forth because they
increase the risk for type 2 diabetes
which doubles a person's risk for
Alzheimer's disease now we've got a
challenge when it comes to nutrition and
brain health if you look at the
evolution of it we're going in a certain
direction
the bad news is that obesity and
overweight actually obesity quadruples a
risk for Alzheimer's but the good news
they've been doing studies of obese
individuals and they find when they lose
weight their memory abilities return in
a matter of months and they follow these
people over time and there are sustained
benefits over the years but as a
challenge you know the neuroscientists
have looked at what goes on in the brain
when we're trying to resist those
cookies and crackers and in this slide
you see some of the brain areas in the
frontal lobe that are controlling these
impulses so there's one part of my brain
that tells me when I see that second
piece of chocolate cake don't eat it
don't eat it but there's another part
right here that's saying eat the cake
eat the cake so it's like a battle of
the brain the good news is if we can
resist initially our neural circuits
actually change so through our own
willpower we can rewire our brains and
it gets easier over time and all of us
know if we've gone on a diet or a
healthy program it's hard to change the
habits initially but over time it gets
easier now there is good news on the
nutrition front it turns out that
alcohol in moderation is associated with
better brain health okay here's some
cheers in the back but then there's
always the question well how much is the
one glass of wine is it like this and
we're not sure why it works it may be
that having a glass of wine at dinner
relaxes us and that helps us with our
brain health or could be chemicals in
the wine one chemical it's called
resveratrol
and it's its anti-aging in the
laboratory so the scientists have
extracted the resveratrol out of the red
wine put it into capsules and now
they're testing it to see if it helps
with Alzheimer's the the challenges were
not sure that the capsule resveratrol
gets into the brain so if anybody's
taking resveratrol capsules just make
sure you wash it down with a nice
Bordeaux
now moderation with caffeine coffee and
tea that's also associated with better
brain health and we're also studying
nutrition we're looking at nutritional
supplements that could help the brain
we've studied pomegranate juice
pomegranate extract we just finished a
study of curcumin which is from turmeric
it's a spice it's it's in encourage
foods in India they consume a lot of
spicy foods they have a lower rate of
Alzheimer's but more importantly it
turns out in the laboratory the curcumin
is anti-inflammatory and it also fights
off those amyloid plaques so we should
be publishing our results this year more
to come in the meantime you might want
to just eat some Indian food every so
often it turns out that people who eat
Indian food more frequently perform
better on memory tests and you'd only
have to eat while you're taking the test
it's fantastic so what else can we do
there's a lot of other things of course
you want to avoid head trauma that's not
good for the brain anybody who's hit
their head and lost consciousness for an
hour or more that doubles their risk for
Alzheimer's you want to stop smoking if
you smoke not not good for your brain
stay positive
keeping a positive outlook helps us live
longer helps us live better and helps
our brain health and then finally you
know get a good doctor listen your
doctor simple things if you have high
blood pressure if you have high
cholesterol just taking your medicine
for the for those problems will improve
your brain health and also help you live
longer now question often comes up can
we prevent Alzheimer's disease and if if
you think of prevention as equivalent to
cure the answer is no but if we think of
prevention as staving off decline or
delaying the onset of symptoms I think
the answer is yes there have been a
number of studies showing that some of
these strategies
exercise eating a healthy diet reducing
stress can make a difference and can
delay the onset of symptoms by years and
we've done studies showing that there's
even an additive effect so if you do one
thing your brain is better if you do two
things it's even better so one way of
thinking about this a sedentary
lifestyle where you're eating all the
wrong things your brain may decline at
this rate but by living a brain healthy
strategy you could delay onset of
symptoms by many years and that can be
very meaningful in people's lives so the
issue is how do we help people change
when people come to see me at UCLA often
you know I'll do the standard medical
approach but also I'll ask them about
their diet and I may say well I want you
to eat this I want you to exercise and
often the response is well well doc
don't you have a pill you know so it's
it's hard to change and I think there's
there is a formula to this there are
things we can do we've tried to
integrate that into our books and I say
our because I want to say my wife Gigi
borgin is a co-author of all my books
and she actually if it weren't for Gigi
the books would have three four sections
introduction methods results and
discussion and no longer Rita but she's
able to make it accessible to a much
wider audience and I appreciate that but
you have to make the information
accessible so the first step is helping
people understand the connection between
brain health and behavior and if we
understand that we're more likely to
make the right decisions we also need to
create programs that are fun and easy my
my latest book is called two weeks to a
younger brain trust me if I'd called it
two years to a younger brain no one
would buy it but two weeks is enough
time to take baby steps and introduce
yourself to these kinds of strategies
and also enough time so you start seeing
results in experiencing results so you
feel better and that's what truly
motivates people for the long haul so
what about the future where are we going
well one of the things that we're
looking at it UCLA is trying to again
look at incentives to get people to
engage in these sorts of programs so
there have been studies looking at these
modifiable risk factors that I've been
talking about modifiable risk factors
for dementia and it turns out they have
a huge impact one study found that up to
half of all Alzheimer cases worldwide
could be attributable to these factors
so one of the studies we're doing right
now we call the UCLA Alzheimer's
prevention project and we're we're
recruiting people actually from the
electronic medical record and we're
getting them on a four hour per week
healthy lifestyle program which is very
inexpensive and what we have a control
group what we ultimately won't a'mma to
show is that these programs save the
health system dollars and if we can do
that then we can export it to lots of
health systems and motivate people in
that way through their health system so
anybody want to volunteer their story
here's a brave woman your look no I want
to hear the story I want to hear your
creative okay wait what why don't you
tell me the story and I'll repeat it
the professor sitting on the beach
he had just ridden a horse he's carrying
a teddy bear okay met sheep so so the
professor met a nun smoking a cigar who
was eating pasta under the palm tree
okay that I think that did deserve a
hand that was a fantastic story
well I I just have a quiet did you the
nun what hold on the nun was smoking the
cigar did did you go to Catholic school
okay so you can see how you can have a
lot of fun with these kinds of
approaches our UCLA longevity Center we
have programs for those sale you did
with names and faces who's this oh boy
Harry okay very good I think I heard a
Mona did not so it's not a perfect
system but that's that's quite good
and who's this Oh sue bangle you and you
notice everybody said sue bangle okay
very good
so it's clear there's a lot we can do to
keep our brains healthy as we age while
we're waiting for science to catch up
with that in those important new
discoveries we all can eat right
exercise keep our minds nimble try to
control stress as best we can the UCLA
longevity Center has a lot of programs
in this area we have memory maintenance
we have memory training we're actually
licensing these programs all over the
country we're now in Canada and we're
starting out in China so there's
tremendous interest in understanding and
helping people live better longer if you
want to get an additional brain exercise
just google us UCLA longevity center so
remember you have much more control than
you think when it comes to keeping your
brain healthy thank you so much
I just I'm going to be out I can't take
questions here but I'm going to be
signing books please join me for more of
the conversation at the book signing
area
ladies down if you are thinking and
coming back when these she's a single
works near right thank you